rossi it's almost valentine's day my
sweet news bug and guess what
what food and wine reports that a v-day
classic is back just in time
sweetheart conversation hearts and
they've been out of the candy game
yes for years okay these are so old
school and they are
back and better than ever i love these
as a kid
i know they've been making tongues
chalky since 1902.
and they're like flirty time capsules
through the years we've had groovy on
them
even to fax me hello and then this
is so great these are all love songs
this year
it's so cute they have like a beyond
like um crazy
in love uh-huh yeah they're really it's
really clever
like you know how they how they do it oh
there's a bunch of different songs uh
all of me oh john legend song that's
sugar sugar
at last oh and james i love it okay
ross you know what also this desk needs
right now what
another sweetheart okay and lucky we
have one waiting in the wings he's an
emmy award-winning actor and
author using his children's books to
reach out
to kids with a powerful and beautiful
message of black
self-love and his latest my little black
book is about a young boy
who visits his grandparents and takes a
powerful trip
through black history so you can also
catch him
um every week on the cbs show be
positive
take a look at this come here
what are you doing you can't drive i'll
take you oh hey excuse me hey put me
down i'm not a child you're lighter than
one
well i skipped breakfast oh don't worry
i got you
please welcome terence tyrell
[Applause]
hello look at you guys you guys look
amazing
it's valentine's day exactly it's
valentine's
day so like we're gonna wear nothing but
red and everything's going to be about
hearts all week well you want to hear
about a valentine that it wasn't a
valentine but a real
cool funny story real quick when i first
get to la you know everybody
when you first get here you're always
hungry you don't know where to go
and i slipped into somebody's birthday
party
and i was on a dance floor that looked
like i was supposed to be there
and now you know this beautiful goddess
turns around and i just remember her
heels are so high
now who is this and it sure was drew
barrymore
and we danced together to lady gaga
let's
dance and you were the nicest amazing
person
and you gave me hope that day i was like
okay
i found food and i met drew barrymore i
ain't going back to mississippi i'm
staying here
so thank you so much i
love that did you that's the entire song
and it wasn't just like a little quick
move
like we danced you did your turn around
and i did the thing on hitch when you
turned around i lost my mind did you
turn back around like
yeah cool cool
oh that makes me so happy yay good
goodness all around speaking of goodness
all around your series of incredible
children's books are so
powerful will you please tell us about
your latest
that you've just released for black
history month my little black book
it's skyler the main character exploring
black history
so he's going he's just taking a normal
walk down to grandma's house
and as he goes he sees the airplane and
you know he reminds us that bessie
coleman was the first
african-american woman to fly airplane
so it's just we find out all these
little cool things in the daily life of
skyler
and we just get excited because
sometimes these amazing inventors they
get
lost so i just want to bring that back
up for all our little babies out there
so yeah my little black book
well me and my daughters will be reading
them you have so many you're very
prolific
all right um there's great news out
there
terence will you hit some headlines with
us yeah let's get it
all right great okay all right well love
is in the air
we know it is valentine's week right
it's right around the corner
but here's a question terence is
flirting dead
i know it's a recent piece in the
guardian a comedian named uh
maeve higgins wrote a personal letter to
flirting
and maeve worries that like because of
wearing masks because we're all at home
that that
because you're terrified to be around
anybody
yeah yes yes what about that thing
though when you're like you know walking
through a park and you catch someone's
eye and you
in the olden days right before corona
you just like smile at somebody
think you can't see that that you're
smiling no no so what do you do now
if you do the batting eye thing you just
look crazy like the mask
maybe we should make like the wink like
a universal like
i'm interested i want more you just
can't tell
wink is creepy um
maybe even if there was like a universal
flirting wave you know what i mean like
a
like this thing like yeah i don't know
that's not bad okay no cr again creepy
how about that but no
i don't think that's going to how about
you me
you did it so flirting is one way
to make endorphins go boom another way
is to learn the art of happiness because
certainly happiness is something that we
can all agree on
changes everything about the way we feel
and there is now a course that's been
being taught by
lori santos at yale university which is
now
about to become available for 500
low-income students
they can apply and take the course
there's also a way on a website called
coursera
that you can sign up for this three
million people already have
three million people and this is one of
the most
popular especially with this particular
professor lori santos
at yale university and now we're all
going to be able to get it
either for free or signing up for it
what do you guys think well it's
like it's a course of psychology of
happiness right so i mean because
nowadays people are really struggling
with this there was something like one
in six people
during this pandemic started therapy for
the first time you know
people are really struggling and i think
it's amazing that they're tackling
happiness from a scientific point of
view terence isn't that interesting
i think it's amazing i think it's really
really needed i think it was needed way
before this
um i think that's what pe was about when
i went to sixth grade they were like no
more p.e i was like what
so i think it's really really needed
because
people just need to be happy you only
have one job throughout the day and
that's just to find little things to
make yourself happy
if that's like going to the grocery
store and take your time walking through
the candle aisle
so yeah i think this is a really really
great opportunity for people to really
really really
just get in touch with self and just be
happy because that's all you need to do
you know
just be happy i don't want to walk
through a candle aisle with you that
sounds
great you know i don't like go i i don't
really cook that well but go through the
candle aisle go through the snack aisle
yeah i know that one i also just really
want to take her course because if
somebody tells me to just be happy or
get happy i want to rip their face off
i'm like
really do you got the manual for that
sorry did i just snap my fingers was
gosh was i just
choosing to feel this overwhelmed and
all i have to do
is be and get happy there is
an art there is work to do there is
a process to actually finding the gift
of happiness and attaining it so i'm
going to take this course i really want
to know what she has to say
absolutely happiness takes
work real work i'll tell you what would
make me happy being back on the dance
floor dancing to
lady gaga with you at a house party that
you're crashing
i love it and your show be positive airs
thursday on cbs and please go out there
and make sure that you get copies of my
little black book as well as the rest of
the series
um thank you terence so much thank you
so much for being you drew
thank you terence thank you so much for
being you and the books you're putting
out into the world
are fierce and powerful and
so meaningful really and truly